- Kevin McCarthy met enfin
la main sur le convoité marteau
du président de la Chambre.
Mais à quel prix?
"C'était facile",
a-t-il lancé ironiquement,
au terme d'unererere soirée
de déchirements en public.
Après des négociations
dramatiques à même le plancher
de lamamambre, du brasse-
camarade entre des élus
républicains, il aura fallu
des jours de chaos et 15 tours
de vote au caucus républicain
c c c couronner Kevin McCarthy.
"Ne nous jugez pas
à notre départ, mais
à notre arrivée", dit McCarthy.
Les paroles d'un élu
aux pieds d'argile.
Les trouble-fêtes de l'aile
la plus à droite de son parti
lui ont soutiré d'én
concessions et seront mieux
équipés pour le faire chanter.
Kevin McCarthy règnera
avec une épée de Damoclès
au-des l l l la tête.
Il leur a promis de modifier
les règles de la Chambre.
Un seul élu pourrait
désormais demander un vote pour.
Des membres du fameux caucus
de la liberté siégeront
à des comités importants,
et leurs volontés seront
priorisées, coononononontrôle
des dépenses, de quoi compliquer
les négociations pour relever
le plafond de la dette
américaine et bonifier l'aide
aiaiaiaiaine, par exemple.
En attendant les prochaines
batailles, Kevin McCarthy
a tenu à remercier un allié.
"Personne ne devrait douter
de l'influence de Donald Trump",
dit-il. Ce dernier aurait
fait des appels pour
l'aider à se faire élire.
Deux ans presque jour pour jour
après l'assaut du capitole,
l'ombre de l'ancien président
plane toujours sur un parti
profondément divisé.
Après le désordre
des derniecececececece stratège
républicain s'impatiente.
"Pour affronter les démocrates
en 2024, il faudraé"é"é"é"é"é",
rappelle-t-il.
Mais d'ici là, combien de temps
avant que le caucus républicain
ne se déchire de nouveau?
"Je n'abandonne jamais",
promet Kevin McCarthy,
même si, pour lui, le plus
difficile est à
Ici Louis Blouin,